and today we have two classes which is
basically and alike this these classes
are essentially for yourselves there is
not that I come with a script for you
but rather this is an opportunity for
you to submit your games games that you
may be proud of or may be wondering what
did I do wrong and then we would have a
backhand Pro but unfortunately all I
have is one score sheet in front of me
so I mean it's a force majeure okay the
following game is between Joe Guarnere
and Nick Karloff okay we open up with E
for this is actually a pretty good move
these things I like this move - okay so
d 4 E 5 Knight f3
give me the pawn Knight d7 dad Knight d7
is actually considered a second-rate
move 97 right away should have issues
and I think it does Bishop c4 an
excellent move an excellent move so the
point of the move Bishop c4 is to put
instant pressure against the pawn on f7
now black has a problem that if he now
tries to play Knight f6 then Knight g5
really is a problem for black and black
has issues
black in the game played Bishop e7 and
white missed an opportunity as is well
known in this position white has a
winning move a winning move Julian
detects e5 d takes e5 Queen d5 who
that's that's nice and that pawn on f7
there's no defense with Knight h6
because simply Bishop takes h6 in the
pawn on f7 is hanging again we see why
the inclusion of Knight f6 and Knight c3
earlier was so very important after
Bishop e7 we now know for sure that
white could have won with the move D
takes e5 as we've seen but instead white
thought everything's copasetic he
castles and black errors once again
black errors with the move c6 it becomes
more more vital for him to play Knight
f6 but at least c6
one good point of the move c6 is that
variation that Julian pointed out with
Queen d5 at least that is no longer
available white has played c3 which
isn't a bad move white fortify his
center and he has a threat his threat is
to play Queen b3 developing a battery
with Queen and Bishop against the pawn
on f7 black has played Knight f6
countering attacking the pawn on e4 and
preparing to get his King out of Dodge
with castles rook e1 very good castles
so at this point none of blacks moves
have been punished and in a sense whites
advantage can can can boil down to the
fact that he has a little bit more space
a little bit more activity in the center
but I believe those positions fully
balanced I don't think that white has an
edge at all
castles Age 3 oops this is a bad move h3
bad move much more standard move in this
position would be the move Bishop b3 h3
allows black an opportunity for either
Knight takes e4 which i think is a very
good move or d5 which i think is a very
good move in both cases black literally
breaks out bad move by black b5 well a
bad move this is like second best it's
not bad bad bad or anything like that
but it's just that d5 or 94 are both
such superior moves for black b5 helps
white do what he wants to do y step back
with his Bishop Bishop d3 Bishop d7 now
after Knight BD too slight plus for
white because his Center is nicely
protected defended White has the
harmonious and well known maneuver
Knight f1 to g3 coming up knight b d2 h
7 h 6 taking control of g5 to keep the
the f7 pawn protected knight f1 well
both sides are playing quite well here I
must say rook e8 night g3 Bishop f8 good
play Bishop c2 okay
so that looks kind of tragic Jones
played Bishop c2 over protecting the
pawn on e4 blaka said okay I'll develop
Queen c8 and it appears as just had a
conversation with his bishop in his rook
and as Bishop says well the c1 diagonal
is not very promising let's play b2 b3
and so okay this move then becomes
justified with the idea that you got out
of the way it might have been again
nicer to include this move a 4y if we
imagine for a moment sake that we
provoked the move a six now what white
can and perhaps should consider is the
move before now can somebody try to
explain to me why B form might be a
better square for the pawn than the b3
squared
give it a shot
you can only be wrong Julian
yeah that's right so if we say here in
this position is the bishop on c2 ideal
no we can't say it's ideal we we can say
it has a task Manning the post defending
the pawn on e4 but it's not like it's
reaching into blacks position if we put
the pawn on b4 however first of all
we're still making room for our bishop
and we're giving ourselves the
possibility of playing Bishop b3 in the
near future so again I like a 4 d3 was
played Oh last point a very important
point a very important point I should
point out is that after the move c5 the
move before really does discourage the
move c5 because after a trade of pawns
we do get a very nice protected passed
pawn on the d5 square now a lot of
grandmasters will look at that pass pawn
on d5 and not be afraid of it they'll
say go ahead and have it
I'll have a good blockade with my bishop
and I'll play a move like c4 and then
this night will come to c5 I just I'm
just one of those players I like having
a pawn protected pass pawn on d5 and I
do like neutralizing the bishop on d7
Julian
okay so the question really your
opponent has a protected past pong what
is the best block hater the best block
hater is a knight full stop end of story
you'd love to have a knight on d6
blockading the pawn ii bought the best
block hater is a bishop yes so the
bishop isn't bad it's not bad
the Knights better but hey the bishops
not bad why is the knight better than
the bishop in such positions why is the
knight better than the bishop the bishop
does a great job locating the the past
pawn all right that that really does but
in terms of the space count does the
bishop help the space count not at all
and the bishop is just defending the
pawns on e5 and c4 c5 so the bishop is
blocked they doesn't attack any of
White's territory conversely we stick a
knight on d6 we understand that nice
doing a great job defending blockading
the d5 point but also as a block hater
it's attacking these squares b4 and c4
so it's reaching into White's camp so
it's doing that dual function like these
Knights of being aggressive in defensive
this Knights being defensive but it's
also being aggressive so the Knights the
best block hater the second best piece
is the bishop and the worst piece is the
Queen the queen is a terrible blockade
err first of all because she's not a
great block hater I mean she does
nothing she just stands there in front
of the palm instead she's got all of
these great powers and she's belittling
herself by simply being a block hater
the worst part about a blockade with the
Queen is the any attack any time the
Queen's attacked the Queen got a run so
I hate her at all you know night pops to
f5 queens gotta run
who rook comes to see six queens running
you know Bishop comes to a 3 and so on
itself all right so we take these moves
back and we put the pawn here we put the
pawn here we don't include the move a4
a6 we just shoot right away with b3 okay
all of these criticisms judgments are
not meant in any measure to say blunder
mistakes mistakes or anything like that
but rather to express the idea that you
can't be absolutely sure that your move
is good like that there's something you
know like you making a move well first
of all you're spending a tempo and
you're oftentimes got to ask yourself is
that the wisest use of a tempo secondly
when you play the move b3 you open up a
diagonal for one Bishop but close it for
the other and again that gets us back to
that b4 move for a second so b3 was
played rook a d8 black is doing fine by
the way black is doing a very good job
this should be too and we can actually
even say that black has developed his
army quicker than white white still
remains with a rook on a1 as well as a
queen on d1 after this move rook on a d8
white might say my white might have said
to himself darn I really regret the fact
I didn't play a for trade trade a pair
of rooks because at the moment it's
blacks rooks that are centralized and
after Bishop b2 black broke in the
center with d5 now I'm not sure if this
move is the best move but it certainly
fits the needs of the
the needs of the position require that
black who's fully developed now takes an
active approach and attacks in the
center d5e takes d5 ok c takes d5 also
something to be recommended for Knight
takes d5 as well but black was very
aggressive he's thinking that with this
pawn on d5 he's beginning to open up his
LightSquared Bishop thankfully from
blacks point of view the move d5 opened
up his dark squared bishop right away D
takes e5 Knight takes e5 Knight d4 ok
well I pardon me white centralizes his
knight black has a centralized Knight
so from whites point of view from whites
point of view white plays this move what
are some of the strategic motifs behind
this move Knight d4 can somebody tell me
from a strategic point of view what this
knight on d4 is all about bingo
absolutely so with the knight
centralized on d4 what you're doing is
blockading the isolated pawn when you
blockade the isolated pawn you're kind
of putting this bishop there's no
sacrifices with d5 d4 so this bishop is
being neutralized ok
secondly the knight on d4 is also
reaching out over here and it's
reminding black that by the way your
pawn on b4 is hanging so the idea what
we would say is that would this move
Knight to d4 we're blockading the pond
we're centralizing our night and we're
attacking this pawn on b4 now then from
blacks point of view
black also has a very nice centralized
night and if I was black I'd be thinking
in terms of continuing the
centralization like I would want even
though we talk about the isolated pawn
at times being weak
I'd also I'd want to be able to jump
into the center and to extend this
diagonal if I can make that work
tactically for the moment I have to pay
attention to my pawn on b5
white black pardon me has played Bishop
c5 okay I'm not a hundred percent sure I
get that move obviously it's nice to
bring this bishop which is okay it's
quietly defending blacks King but with
the Bishop on c5 it's aims at White's
King and maybe this pawn on f2 I'm not a
hundred percent sure how this move
defends this pawn on b5 so if I was in
black shoes with this pawn on b5 I would
be considering Queen b6 just defending
the pawn I would be considering the move
b5 before yeah attacking the pawn and if
you take I take with the bishop and
attack the rook but after the move
Bishop c5 I think that this pawn on b5
is hanging rook c1 okay Joe why didn't
you take
okay no words okay yeah well rook c1 is
definitely I put that in the category of
a safe move I'm one of those I'm an old
pond grubber you know I give me that a
give me your pawns baby it out like
Julian yeah I'm not sure I didn't quite
see it yeah me too
if for any any moment the Queen b6 check
to the king and to the night the night
would jump back so what you're looking
at is maybe to go on a rampage like this
the only problem is I think you're
giving up to you you've given up to
pieces already and I'm not a hundred
percent sure you got enough right do you
have enough sorry
check I can it's two pieces it's a lot
- peace - peace
this I think is is not enough I mean
it's definitely something that like you
said you're in time trouble you might
see a move like Bishop F do and Knight
g4 and say I'm not gonna give my phone
at that chance but on the other hand
when you get a concrete moment concrete
opportunity to win a pawn that looks
like a gift boy I mean I feel like a
bank robber yeah like I'll take it I'll
take it if I can if I if I feel I can
get away with it I'll take it
Knight takes d4 wasn't played rook c1
developing a piece although I'm not
quite sure I feel that that's such an
effective use maybe I would prefer maybe
a move like Queen d2 or rookie three
followed by rook e1 trying something
like that
rook C one for the moment looks like a
kind of a pass move not bad not good it
is okay a six okay
a six no this move I like Knight g5
bringing your knight into the game
nights on f5 especially against the h6
g7 f7 pawn structures are very good it's
very hard for black to get rid of that
night you can't really play g6 because
the h6 pawn is on pre however the
drawback is that you're giving up
control of the e4 square and indeed
black jump with his knight 94 oh boy so
as things have progressed I would say
that black has a considerable advantage
black has a considerable advantage why
would I say that well it's a very
interesting thing about Knights Knights
a short-range pieces you've got to get
them into your opponent's camp you got
to get you
it's a to bring them forward Knights
love centralized squares so while the
Knights are a little bit off setting
each other at the moment there's
something else that night will of
Knights crave protection okay the more
and Knight is defended the stronger it
is now if we think about it in our mind
if we imagine a knight in the center of
the board in the outpost in the center
that can't get pushed away and it's
supported by all kinds of ponds the
opponent never really wants to capture
the night because then the pawns
recapture and the knight gets to sit
down and then in the middle the board
blacks Knights better defended than
whites Knights
this Knight has one defender the other
night Boris Spassky decided described
these two Knights as standing on each
other's hooves yeah that their potential
is reduced because they're in the state
of mutual protection this Knight is only
defended once whereas if you look at
blacks Knights they're defended multiple
times this knight on e4 by the pawn by
the bishop by the rook this knight on e5
by the rope by the Queen
so these Knights are actually better
than whites Knights next if we look at
the bishops we can compare their
activity to one another we might not be
overjoyed by this Bishop on b7 it is
there we're a little bit more yeah
that's a bit of a better Bishop on c5
but these two bishops are rather passive
yeah secondly we compare we make a
comparative observation about the
Queen's this Queen on d1 has not
developed this Queen on c7 have we make
a comparative observation about the
rooks the rooks on e1 and rook on EE a
cancel each other out they're equal this
rook on c1 has less potential in the
rotunda
yeah so from a comparative point of view
nights are better blacks bishops are
better as Queen is better and his rooks
are slightly better so white is stands
worse it's really that simple white
makes a big move and I'm going to say a
bad move big move f2f for in the
immortal words of Viktor Korchnoi pawns
don't move backwards and when you play
the move like this knight on e4 is a
good night but it's not a Thor a god of
thunder it's a it could be potentially
it's outpost is not eternal
there's f2 f3 that could push it then
I'm not saying that F 2 F 3 is a good
mode but I'm saying that F 2 F 3 exists
is an option in the position for for
white when white plays the move F 2 F 4
he has to he does so under the
realization that with this move that
knight on e4 ain't moving it's there
forever
right so it's sort of like you as white
Joe when you play this move f4 you might
get yourself all hot and excited that
you're attacking a knight on e5 in
forcing it to move but from blacks point
of view black sit there says who I'm
really happy about that move well I my
knight on e4 it's it's gonna hang on
there for a long time
f4 Knight g6 and by the way retreating
the knight has opened up a pretty juicy
target this pawn on f4 is vulnerable to
the night under the queen g3 defending
and I must say that Black has played
very well I like what Black has done so
from my point of view if I was in black
shoes I would be
smacking my lips a little bit here I
would start thinking can I play the move
Knight takes F for G takes f for Queen
takes F for my queen would be
threatening to capture the night thanks
to the pin my queen might be threatening
to come to F to check so Knight takes f4
starts to be attractive a little bit or
a lot of it but I might think that after
Knight f4 gf for Queen takes f4 oops I
gotta be a little bit careful there is a
move Queen g5 the Queen d1 to g4 with a
threat of Queen g7 mate queen f2 check
King h1 and I don't have Knight g3 mate
because there's a knight on f5 so while
I may find Knight f4 very attractive I
would try to go through the calculations
I like what black did black took another
approach in this position he said the
bishop on b7 is not fully functioning
he's having this conversation with his
pieces right saying hey buddy can you
earn your keep can you do a little bit
more and the Bishop says yeah I can I'll
play Bishop back to c8
I'll threaten to take the knight if the
knight moves looky looky I got a pawn
and you should know I live for pawns you
know Bishop takes Asia so I like this
move Bishop c8 Bishop takes e4 D takes
e4 I like this move D takes e4 if we
consider I'm not saying it's absolute
but if we consider the idea that black
is on the attack that blacks got the
initiative he's got his mojo going
whenever you're on the attack avoid
unnecessary peace trades when you're
when you trade pieces you're losing
firewood to make a bonfire so you
capture on e4 with a pawn and don't
trade rooks because
you're losing firewood so I like what
white/black has played marvelously here
Bishop takes D takes before this night
is hanging behind it stands the pawn on
h3 these two Knights are mutually
defending but this Bishop on c5 is
terrifying this pawn can be undermined
with a break like before so a lot of
good things are happening in this
position for black and whites in deep
trouble queen h5 probably forced oh okay
hey good man okay good yeah get rid of
that knight on e4 okay so the Queen on
h5 first of all we might say that this
is this move is aggressive that
black-white activates his queen at last
it brings it into the game but the true
reality of this move is actually it was
required in the sense that the knight
couldn't move the Queen actually ends up
protecting the night and as well as
protecting the pawn on h3 so Queen h5
Queen b6 was played okay so let me just
stop here for a second so hmm
well one of the moves I'm very attracted
to is I would love to play this move
rook to d5 why from my point of view of
black I'm putting this knight on f5 into
a pin to the Queen and I'm preparing to
play the move Bishop takes d4 and to
take this Knight there's a small problem
the knight could move away with a
discovered check and oh dear
the Queen the rook isn't protected so
even though I would find this move
we'll take rip to d5 as strategically
very attractive tactically it doesn't
work so maybe I would make a move to
prepare route d5 I might play King h7
Julian I considered it a move ago before
that this Knight was captured but did
you have a specific follow-up after
Queen takes f4 or you have a you're
threatening to play Queen takes f5 as
well as Bishop and again thanks to this
pin right so I'm assuming rook f1
okay but you sacrificed a piece for two
pawns let's just go back to c7 for a
second and I'm thinking that maybe white
is prepared to play on the night takes
g7 rook g1 e3 just a second I'll check
my rulebook yes it's legal yes good man
but I don't know I think white might
might get you first is don't you find
this a little frightening night h6 g h6
Queen h6
right so I'm not exactly 100% sure but
okay let's say I just take with the idea
of rook g1 if Bishop d7 check let's say
I'll have to drop my bring my rook up to
f3 so I'm thinking that if it's my turn
I'll get to play rook Jiwon not sure you
could take my rook take and maybe you
should play a move like
okay so to sacrifice your queen
yeah so something like this perhaps yes
and from whites point of view it's like
he's got to ask this partner he says
give me a rook
give me a knight you know like I got to
get some checkmate action going
so from whites point of view his queen
needs help
okay so c-4 to give me something okay
Bishop d4 looks kind of forced and let's
see so let's give you a check and you
got I think you got to go to the H line
if you go to f8 I've got a nasty check
on the diagonal waiting I don't think
you can go to h8 maybe I could take and
yeah so I'm thinking h7 for for the
moment yeah and let me take the bishop
threatening mate trade let me take this
pawn yeah something like this and right
there's a there's a check that defends
the knight in case so yeah I mean again
those sacrifice with Knight takes f4 I
think that those types of calculations
would would be going through my mind
like I would be thinking can I get away
with with this sacrifice okay what do I
got
Knight is here pawn is perhaps here
Knight is perhaps
here pawn is here in here or was the
night I'm sorry I'm missing some some
wood yeah missing some wood and another
night on that fight correct
how did it get down as you on okay so we
got this position and we were just
looking at some possible fun variation
with night f4 and I was thinking that
the move rook d5 was a killer just a
stone-cold killer except it loses
tonight h6
so in my mind's eye what I might find
myself very attracted to is a pre not a
pre entry a preparatory move ah I knew
existed there was a word a preparatory
move like the move king h7 and I'm you
know hands are waving I'm saying looky
looky I've got this idea of utilizing my
centralized rooks to play rook d5 and to
cause white again in the words of Viktor
Korchnoi unpleasant sensation rook d5
will evoke unpleasant sensations black
has has played a pretty reasonable move
I it might even be a better move than
King h7 black has played the move Queen
b6 yeah Queen b6 so from blacks point of
view he's putting additional pressure on
this diagonal maybe he decides that the
Queen might even be a little bit more
frisky
over here on the f6 square maybe he's
thinking that if he takes this night he
wants to be out of the way of the rook
and finally he could also be thinking
that hey with the move b4 to undermine
the knight on d4 so the move Queen b6
certainly does look attractive
along with Julian's Knight f4 when we
calculate the way we calculate you need
to see these Grand Master's man I saw
this this this this this this we go wow
how did he calculate that line when we
calculate Grand Master's the first thing
in our checklist of calculations is
check yeah any checks so we look at
checks first if checks don't exists we
just look at the wrecked captures so if
I were black and I'm trying to get an
advantage the first move I would
calculate is does the move Bishop takes
d5 do I get an advantage with this move
does that bring me advantage I can
calculate I take the McKnight he's got
to take my bishop cool the next thing is
I go okay I can calculate this so and by
the way how sweet it is it comes with
check ah jack right so I've just given
up two bishops for two nights he's got
to recapture now I again I continue the
line I don't give up because what
attracts me to this Siri sequence of
moves is why it's king I'm attracted to
the sequence of moves because I think
that this pawn shield has been a little
pushed a little bit further ahead and
make black White's King a little bit
vulnerable so I continue the sequence in
my mind I'll play Queen a five loops my
queen is under attack I'm going to
comply Queen a5 why do I continue
the sequence of moves well I start to
think huh isn't this interesting first
of all I'm threatening to capture upon
which would attack the bishop which
would attack another pawn and if I can
go eat eat eat you know I live for one
pawn give me three I'm ecstatic joy as
you know like carrying me out you know
okay so Queenie so I think that myself
mentally
okay the Queen comes out here I'm gonna
go here here eat eat eat oh look at this
I can also bring my queen to this
attractive Square D - and maybe in
connection with this pawn I can also
push my pawn up the board so I would I
would concretely calculate Bishop takes
f5 Bishop takes d4 Queen a5 like if Joe
if Joe once we can continue the
calculation and we could go Luke takes
e4 then in my mind the first move I'm
going to calculate as Queen takes a -
I'm gonna say haha I'm gonna get that
pawn back right like yeah yeah I lose I
lose a pawn I gotta have a good reason
I'm gonna get it back the second thing I
might look at is hey how about Queen d2
how're you gonna defend your Bishop
right
so the as a if in my calculation my
judgement brought me to a position where
I was dissatisfied with Bishop takes f5
and Bishop takes d4 I would start to
think about Knight takes f4 yeah I would
start to think about King h7 but I would
definitely be thinking in terms of
capturing right away in that position we
just analyzed by the way we came to a
rather interesting moment and that
moment was night versus Bishop how many
of you recognize the fact that there was
a there was a imbalance white had a dark
squared Bishop black had a knight on
six the night on g6 was no great shakes
but on the other hand that night g6 had
potential if if a black queen lands on
g3 and Knight takes f4 is a stone-cold
winner right so that white would have
had an isolated pawn or a passed pawn in
all of those things and also my judgment
was it would be like hey is that a
position where my Knights better than
his Bishop I anytime I get an advantage
I think okay got me an advantage need a
little bit more hey what else can I get
a cheap so Bishop f5 I'd calculate rook
d5 would be my first choice of course
regrettably Knight h6 losses so King h7
so if we would have if black could
achieve this position in other words
according to the world make two moves in
a row which is illegal we could say
white resigns gonna take your king right
exactly but if black could achieve this
setup he's losing a piece the the
Knights are stuck to one another the pin
it's it's terrible so King h7 with the
idea of rook d5 gets my attention bishop
fi gets my attention Knight f4 gets my
attention so running down my checklist
this looks like a reasonable move but it
would probably be my third perhaps four
choice but not bad not bad King H two
recognizing correctly the King's in deep
doo-doo King H - okay b4 okay again this
is like a kind of a running down the
list but we didn't mention that this
move b4 can be frightening again it's
that double-edged sword when you play
the move b4 you really got to pat
yourself on the back say yeah baby
I'm really undermining this night but
we're also opening up this Bishop right
if that night for some reason doesn't
follow and we we answer takes on before
where the bishop takes before we might
we might just be playing into White's
hands and opening up the bishop on b2
rook on c1 to d1 okay
so white says hey you're attacking my
night I'm going to defend it B takes c3
Bishop takes c3 Bishop takes f5 oh not
sure I like that so much Bishop takes f5
Knight takes f5 and boy has suddenly the
world turned there's an issue is a very
big issue to be addressed Bishop as
being threatened the bishop has to go
back so I would say the last two three
moves have seen blacks advantage drop a
lot like yeah yeah sort of like joy and
happiness just came up white has played
the move Bishop d4 and as you say Joe
you warned me going in that Queen c7 and
I guess the rest of the game devolved
into a time scramble and you didn't have
to score you stopped taking score at
this point how did the game
okay right right well I would say that
that what has happened in fact is this
is barley one of your bed better moments
in the game than it whether that
happened prior and that you've actually
defended pretty good and I would say all
three results are possible here yeah
but an intriguing game with which is
just the the type of game that I love to
analyze I always think that well play
chess games are really a battle of ideas
yeah you come to the game with your
ideas and whoever has ideas or superior
is going to win having said that my
favorite type of game is the total crush
I am NOT one of those people that like
you know 21:24 football games no no no
when the Dallas Cowboys are playing I
like 28:9 that's beautiful that's a
beautiful football game and so I really
like the chess games that are total
crushes where you just wipe the guy out
we just never had a chance but having
said that these these games are also
very very good they learn a lot and you
learn to appreciate that in fact every
every move has its upsides and downsides
and we certainly see that here as that
Bishop just kind of came to life a
moment ago we're gonna take a pause it's
a 20 10 minute break anybody got a game
or something to come back and I'd love
to look at a game